i want to be your assistant
really
you hate it here so do you
i'll make sure you don't have to go to
any meetings
if anyone comes to see you i'll scare
them away
wait april if you had to choose between
these two ties
you're hired
i just figured i might as well get paid
for being here
ten months ago she was an intern who
could give a crap about local government
now
she's our newest employee to april
cheerios yay
jerry come and celebrate
no thanks well everybody let's get back
to work
where are you going
i want to talk to ron about the size of
my desk
jerry
you have to schedule an appointment
okay how about now ron's not here he's
right there i i can see him
i'll let you know when he's available
and a girl
morning
is leslie here
oh man i am so
tired i took a half shift at the
hospital last night
and i had this really weird patient
weird how
i probably shouldn't talk about as one
of the grossest things i've ever seen
talk
well this guy came in he got his hand
stuck in a pringles can
and he tried to cut himself out what
kind of blade did he use
uh three and a half inch
serrated buckets of blood he passed out
over his arm and slumped onto the floor
did the boncho very good question april
answer her
yeah the bone showed everyone in the
universe loves a gross medical story
boom
i win
and so when i finally cleaned up the
vomit i found the toe i forgot about the
towel so did we
crazy right that story is awesome indeed
thank you for sharing jenny
ann was getting a little chummy
when people get too chummy with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them that's a genius move thank you
you're welcome lester
the parks and rec
confirming what
that's not possible
oh no
hey good morning why are there six
people outside who say they're waiting
to meet with me so you know how you love
me because you haven't had a single
meeting with anyone since i became your
assistant that's because
every time someone calls and requests a
meeting with you i always schedule it
for march 31st
why because i didn't think march 31st
existed
30 days has september april march and
november june and november
today is march 31st i know
so then how many meetings do i have
today
93. okay
okay well you know what to do
right
to me
this situation is a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape
however to leslie knope oh how fun
yay why don't you take as many as you
can and i'll cover the rest i have a
better idea why don't i try to rustle up
seven more meetings cause i think it
would be cooler if there were even a
hundred why don't we just stick to these
93 and see how it goes yeah okay
well hello there
you must be ron swanson well welcome to
casa ludgate hello mr ludger ah call me
larry larry who is it it's zuzu's boss
oh ron rita ludgate oh you have no idea
how nice it is to meet you
but oh come in for god's sake
what can i get you to drink ooh could
you take your shoes off please thank you
so much
uh nothing to drink thanks oh okay is
april around uh zuzu you have a guest
i'll fetch her she's probably on the
internet again
uh i'll come with you okay okay uh you
make yourself at home mr swanson thank
you
you must be april's sister
i'm ron
nice to meet
you why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
i want you to come back well i don't
want to come back
the end
i was talking to andy about you
and he made me realize that i need you
back at work what did he say
don't recall fine i'll come back
good
okay i'm leaving
bye zuzu
bye
duke silver
my mom has all your albums
i recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
oh excuse me i had a meeting with ron
swanson yesterday but head of car
trouble sorry he's busy right now oh uh
well can i reschedule sure hmm how about
june 50th
sorry do you think you could come back
today at 265. he's available then
what is going on looks like the only
other day he has open is march september
19th does that work sir
[Music]
hey bro
listen i was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b25
mitchell panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and i went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey ron
swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are
yeah
okay um there are these things called
cookies where like if you go to a site
and buy something it'll remember you and
then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to google
earth and type in your address
would you like to sample our vegan bacon
100 meatless
yes please
another please
sir is there a problem i'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this i i
don't think i can give you any more i
want one
i love food and stuff it's where i buy
all of my food
and most of my stuff
hey can i get these
how much are there
two bucks a piece
good deal
anything else
nope
just the crows and the beef
do you fish april no for sure gross let
me give you a piece of fishing advice i
said when you have a fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about maybe not
maybe you really do hate andy maybe
moving to indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do i know
[Music]
motion sensors
do you live here
april
yeah
do you live here
no
catch
yeah i thought so
i went home but i had this strange
feeling that there was something wrong
with you so i came back
it's just a minor medical issue
aids
no i'm safe
blindness
no is it like a parasite or a virus or
something you get from a bee
i have a hernia do you have syphilis i
said it's a hernia i know
it's possible to have two things
do you need a ride to the hospital
yes please
okay
but i rode my bike here so i have to go
home and get my dad's station wagon
thank you
bye
you're still here yeah
i just wanted to see if you could tell
are you still here
you